And now, Great Moments
in Unintended Consequences.
Part one: The Yacht Plot.
The year, 1990.
The problem, a national debt that had exploded.
The solution, a 10 percent luxury tax on expensive boats.
Sounds like a great idea with the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
It turns out that while wealthy people buy yachts,
it's usually middle-income people who make them.
This giant middle finger of a tax plan
cut sales of luxury boats by 70 percent,
sent companies overseas or into Chapter 11,
destroyed hundreds of thousands of middle class jobs,
and resulted in a net loss in tax revenue.
Turns out it was all for yacht.
Part two: Who's Hungry Mao?
The year is 1958.
The problem, birds eating too much grain in China.
The solution, Chairman Mao labels
the Eurasian sparrow as a capitalist enemy of the state,
kicking off a nationwide campaign to eradicate the species.
Sounds like an idea,
with the best of intentions!
What could possibly go wrong?
It turns out sparrows also eat insects,
and insects eat a lot more grain than sparrows do.
100 million dead birds later,
grain yields plummeted in China,
resulting in massive famine, starvation, and deaths
estimated between 15 and 45 million people.
On the bright side, at least China learned its lesson
about rounding up unwanted populat-
Part three: Vaccination Proclamations.
The year, 2021.
The problem, effective distribution for a vaccine
with a short shelf life.
New York's solution, create a massively detailed
yet questionable priority schedule.
Then mandate appointments, pushing applicants,
including the elderly, toward a buggy website
to answer lengthy questionnaires
and upload multiple attachments.
When that slows things down, find distribution centers
for giving about-to-expire doses to non-priority patients.
When they throw expired doses away,
fine them for not using their entire supply fast enough.
Also remove the priority status
of frontline workers who don't get it early enough
and threaten the strip medical licenses
and future vaccine delivery
for those who don't comply with all the rules created
and changed on a daily basis.
Sounds like (groans).
Come on, New York, get it together.
Just don't forget to cover up nursing home deaths
and blame the federal government
when you collect your Emmy!
Great Moments in Unintended Consequences.
Good intentions, bad results.